I'm, uh -- I'm doing better.
[ Laughter ]
I -- I just turned 39,
you know, which is --
[ Cheers and applause ]
Okay. Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, it's not old.
It's not -- It's not old.
But I think we can all agree
that I am running out of time.
Sure. Yeah.
I got about one year left
on this fun little outfit.
And then I got to regroup.
I've got to become
a businessman next year.
I've got to start talking
like a 40-year-old.
I've got start staying
40-year-old words.
Like, "Terrific.
"This is bull."
"Absolute bull."
"This is a lease."
"You're not on the lease!"
[ Laughter ]
All of a sudden gonna wake up
with a 14-year-old son
named Michael.
"Get your head out of your butt,
Michael!
Quit loafing around
and get a job!
You're up there
playing your vidya games!"
[ Laughter ]
When I was 14, my dad hated
I did not have a job.
He was always like,
"Quit loafing around!
Get a job!"
I was like, "I'm 14!
I think it's illegal."
[ Laughter ]
He's like, "You're going to
print off some résumés."
I was like,
"Print off some résumés?
What am I gonna put on the
résumé? I've never had a job.
[ Light laughter ]
I kid you not,
he made me print off résumés,
and all they said on them was,
"Raked Judith Hoye's leaves."
[ Laughter ]
I walked into businesses.
I was like, "Here's my CV.
Give Judith Hoye a ring."
[ Laughter ]
I got fired from
a lot of jobs growing up.
One job I got fired from
when I was a teenager --
this is 100% true --
is I was a house painter.
I used to paint the outside
of people's homes.
And how I got fired from
that job is, long story short,
um...
I painted the wrong house.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yeah, so, painted
the wrong house,
and then I guess
what happened was,
is the people who live there,
they left for work
early in the morning,
you know, stupidly assuming
no one's gonna paint their home.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah.
Yeah, and then we pulled in the
driveway like one second later
and committed a crime
for eight hours.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah. In the sun.
And then our boss finally
figured out where we were.
He was like, "Oh, my God!
You painted the wrong house!"
And this is --
And then -- You know.
And this is how
we solved the problem.
Now, pay close attention.
We packed everything up
and drove away.
[ Laughter ]
Yeah. Yeah.
And then we were fired
on the way home.
That makes sense. We're morons.
But what that means, though,
is I never got to find out
what happened to that family
when they got home from work
and their house
was a different color!
[ Laughter ]
And nobody had any answers.
When they started their day,
they owned a white house
with gray trim.
And when they finished their
day, their house was brown.
[ Laughter ]
Brown!
Now, sometimes people ask me --
They go,
"But what shade of brown?"
And I'm like -- I don't know.
I like to describe it
as a noticeable brown.
Uh, yeah, the kind of brown
you're going to notice
your house is a completely
different color
than when
you started your day --
and wet.
Now, I don't know what
that couple said to each other
when they got home.
I have no idea.
But I'm pretty sure
they did not say a single word.
Because how do you ask
your spouse
if your house was always brown?
I don't know.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you very much.